>>> HELLO, AND THANKS FOR BEING
WITH ME ON THIS FRIDAY, I'M ANA
CABRERA IN NEW YORK, THE PUSH
FOR TRUTH DID NOT PREVAIL.
SENATE REPUBLICANS JUST BLOCKED
A BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO
INVESTIGATE THE JANUARY 6th
CAPITOL ATTACK, JUST SIX
REPUBLICANS VOTED IN FAVOR OF
THIS EFFORT TO GET THE REAL
ANSWERS.
ON WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT DARK
DAY.
JUST SIX.
KEEP IN MIND, SEVEN REPUBLICAN
SENATORS VOTED TO CONVICT DONALD
TRUMP FOR INCITING THAT
INSURRECTION.
BUT APPARENTLY, AN EVEN SMALLER
NUMBER WANT TO GET ANSWERS ABOUT
THAT ATTACK ON AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
HERE'S SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> THE REPUBLICAN MINORITY JUST
PREVENTED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FROM GETTING THE FULL TRUTH
ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
THE REPUBLICAN MINORITY JUST
PREVENTED THE SENATE FROM EVEN
DEBATING THE BILL.
SHAME ON THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
FOR TRYING TO SWEEP THE HORRORS
OF THAT DAY UNDER THE RUG
BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID OF DONALD
TRUMP.
>> LET'S GET YOU RIGHT TO THE
HILL WITH CNN'S RYAN NOBLES,
RYAN, THE FINAL VOTE WAS 54-35.
HOW IS IT THAT THE 35 WIN?
>> YEAH, IT DOES PROBABLY MAKE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME
SCRATCH THEIR HEADS THAT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
SENATORS VOTED TO MOVE THIS
COMMISSION FORWARD, BUT IT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH AND THAT'S THE
WAY THE UNITED STATES SENATE
WORKS BECAUSE IT REQUIRES A
SUPERMAJORITY IF THE MINORITY
PARTY INTENDS TO FILIBUSTER
SOMETHING, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE SAW HERE TODAY, THIS VOTE
FALLING SHORT, ONLY 54 VOTING
YES, AND IT DID INCLUDE A
COLLECTION OF REPUBLICANS, SIX
REPUBLICANS, LISA MURKOWSKI OF
ALASKA VOTING YES, SUSAN COLLINS
OF MAINE, BILL CASSIDY OF
LOUISIANA, BEN SASSE OF
NEBRASKA, MITT ROMNEY OF UTAH,
AND ROB PORTMAN OF OHIO, NOW
THERE WAS ANOTHER SENATOR, PAT
TOOMEY FROM PENNSYLVANIA, I
SHOULD SAY, WHO WAS NOT HERE
TODAY, HE WAS AMONG A COLLECTION
OF REPUBLICANS THAT JUST DIDN'T
VOTE AT ALL.
NOW TOOMEY DID RELEASE A
STATEMENT THIS AFTERNOON SAYING
HE WOULD HAVE VOTED YES HAD HE
BEEN IN ATTENDANCE BUT HE HAD A
FAMILY COMMITMENT.
POINTING OUT THAT HAD HE BEEN
HERE IT WOULDN'T HAVE MATTERED
BECAUSE THIS COLLECTION OF
REPUBLICANS THAT WE ARE SHOWING
YOU HERE, THAT WERE NOT HERE TO
VOTE WOULD HAVE -- ASIDE FROM
TOOMEY, ALL VOTED NO.
AND IT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED TEN
REPUBLICANS TO PUSH THE BILL
FORWARD.
SO, ANA, THERE IS A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION AMONG DEMOCRATS
RIGHT NOW.
SOME SUGGESTING THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF WHY THEY NEED TO BLOW
UP THE FILIBUSTER BECAUSE IT'S
SO DIFFICULT TO GET ANYTHING
ACCOMPLISHED.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO ANA REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS WERE CALLING FOR.
DEMOCRATS MADE A NUMBER OF
CONCESSIONS TO REPUBLICANS TO
GET THEM ON BOARD, IT JUST
WASN'T ENOUGH.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS MEANS,
RYAN, FOR THOSE SIX REPUBLICANS
WHO VOTED IN FAVOR OF THE
COMMISSION, IS THIS FIGHT WITHIN
THE GOP OVER?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO
FORECAST, ANA, BECAUSE AMONG
THIS GROUP YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS THAT JUST WON
REELECTION, SO THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FORCED TO
FACE VOTERS IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THERE'S ALSO SOME THAT HAVE JUST
DECIDED NOT TO RUN FOR
REELECTION, SO THEY'RE ALSO NOT
GOING TO FACE THE WRATH OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS IN AN ELECTION.
BUT I WANT TO JUST READ FOR YOU
A BIT OF WHAT BILL CASSIDY, THE
SENATOR OF LOUISIANA SAID, AFTER
THIS VOTE, HE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AND HE SAID, QUOTE,
THE INVESTIGATIONS WILL HAPPEN
WITH OR WITHOUT REPUBLICANS TO
ENSURE THAT INVESTIGATIONS ARE
FAIR, IMPARTIAL, AND FOCUSED ON
THE FACTS REPUBLICANS NEED TO BE
INVOLVED.
AND THIS KIND OF GETS TO THE
POINT OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE, ANA, THAT
REPUBLICANS, TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT, ARE HURTING THEMSELVES
BY NOT ALLOWING THIS COMMISSION
TO GO FORWARD.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI PUT
OUT A STATEMENT SAYING THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GIVING UP ON
THIS, THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
DON'T CONTINUE TO SEEK THE
TRUTH.
INSTEAD OF THIS BEING AN
INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
COMMISSION WE'RE LOOKING AT A
PARTISAN COMMISSION RUN BY
DEMOCRATS WHERE THEY'LL GET TO
CALL THE SHOTS, AND SO THEREFORE
THAT'S GOING TO MEAN A GOOD
PORTION OF AMERICANS ARE GOING
TO QUESTION THE FINAL OUTCOME.
>> THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
RYAN NOBLES, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORTING.
>>> REPUBLICANS APPARENTLY
DIDN'T SEE THE NEED TO
INVESTIGATE THIS RIOT.
BUT HERE ARE THE FACTS.
NO, JANUARY 6th WAS NOT A NORMAL
TOURIST VISIT AS GEORGIA
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ANDREW
CLYDE FALSELY CLAIMS, HE KNOWS
THIS, HE KNOWS BETTER BECAUSE HE
HAVE IMAGES OF HIM FROM THAT
VERY DAY HELPING TO BARRICADE
THE DOORS OF THE HOUSE GALLERY
TO KEEP OUT THE VIOLENT MOB.
NO, JANUARY 6th WAS NOT NORMAL.
IT WAS THE SINGLE WORST ATTACK
ON OUR NATION'S CAPITOL SINCE
THE WAR OF 1812.
THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK LEFT FIVE
PEOPLE DEAD.
IT LEFT MORE THAN 140 OTHERS
INJURED.
AN ATTACK THAT SAID LAWMAKERS
AND FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIKE
PENCE RUNNING FOR THEIR LIVES.
AN ATTACK CARRIED OUT LARGELY BY
TRUMP SUPPORTERS, AND ENCOURAGED
BY TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES.
>> WE FIGHT LIKE HELL.
IF YOU DON'T FIGHT LIKE HELL,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
COUNTRY ANYMORE.
>> LET'S HAVE TRIAL BY COMBAT.
>> AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THIS WAS ALL
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT LIKE THE
RESULT OF A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION THAT WAS NOT IMPACTED
BY WIDESPREAD VOTER FRAUD.
NO FACTS, NO EVIDENCE SUPPORTING
OTHERWISE, NOTHING.
AND THAT HAS BEEN BACKED UP BY
MULTIPLE RECOUNTS AND AUDITS AND
COURT RULINGS AND YET EVEN TODAY
56% OF REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THE
ELECTION WAS RIGGED.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF LIES.
THE MOB WAS FED LIES.
AND POLICE OFFICERS WERE
SAVAGELY BEATEN, SPRAYED WITH
CHEMICALS, DRAGGED DOWN CONCRETE
STEPS, TRAMPLED, HIT WITH FIRE
EXTINGUISHERS, CRUSHED WITH RIOT
SHIELDS AND ATTACKED WITH STUN
GUNS.
>> I EXPERIENCED THE MOST
BRUTAL, SAVAGE, HAND TO HAND
COMBAT OF MY ENTIRE LIFE, LET
ALONE MY POLICING CAREER, WHICH
SPANS ALMOST TWO DECADES.
>> CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER BRIAN
SICKNICK DIED SUFFERING TWO
STROKES ON THE DAY AFTER HE
CONFRONTED THE MOB.
LAWMAKERS CAME TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE OFFICER SICKNICK'S
SACRIFICE BUT GIVING HIM THE
RARE DISTINCTION OF LYING IN
HONOR IN THE CAPITOL THAT HE
BRAVELY DEFENDED.
OFFICER SICKNICK'S MOTHER SAYS
THE LAWMAKER STANDING IN THE WAY
OF THAT BIPARTISAN COMMISSION
ARE FAILING HER SON AND THE
NATION.
>> THIS WAS A -- CONSTITUTION
AND RIGHT NOW I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE DOING IT.
>> LET'S BRING IN CNN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND FORMER
U.S. CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF
TERRENCE GAINER, WHAT IS YOUR
MESSAGE TO REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED
AGAINST THIS COMMISSION?
>> WELL, ANA, I, LIKE A LOT OF
OTHERS, ARE DISAPPOINTED IN
THIS, BUT IRONICALLY EARLIER
THIS MORNING I WAS IN A VA
CLINIC ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO AND IN THE LOBBY THERE'S
A PHOTO OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN WITH
THE WORDS TO CARE FOR THOSE WHO
BORE THE BATTLE.
I THINK TODAY'S VOTE SHOWED THAT
THEY DO NOT CARE FOR THOSE WHO
BORN THE BATTLE AND TO HELP
PREVENT SOMETHING LIKE THAT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN.
IT NEEDS A COMPREHENSIVE, REAL
INVESTIGATION, NOT THESE STOVE
PIPE THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON IN
MULTIPLE BRANCHES OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD MOMENT FOR
OUR CONGRESS AND IS CERTAINLY
NOT WHAT WE EXPECTED.
I THINK THEY'VE LET THE CAPITOL
POLICE AND OTHERS DOWN SEVERELY.
>> SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO
MET WITH THE MOTHER OF FALLEN
POLICE OFFICER BRIAN SICKNICK
YESTERDAY WHO THEN VOTED NO
TODAY, HE RELEASED A STATEMENT
SUGGESTING THE OFFICERS THAT HE
ALSO MET WITH, INCLUDING OFFICER
FANONE WHO WE JUST PLAYED A CLIP
OF THAT THEY TESTIFIED BEFORE
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE.
GRAHAM SAYING THIS I WILL
SUGGEST THE TESTIMONY OF THE TWO
OFFICERS AND OTHERS BE CAPTURED
TO DISPEL ANY NOTION THAT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th WAS
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A VIOLENT
VICIOUS ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
IS A COMMITTEE HEARING ENOUGH?
>> ABSOLUTELY IT IS NOT AND
SENATOR GRAHAM OUGHT TO KNOW
BETTER.
SO MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THAT
SENATE ARE EITHER LAWYERS,
LITIGATORS, FORMER PROSECUTORS,
EVEN SOME U.S. ATTORNEYS.
THEY KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
FULL-TIME INVESTIGATION, NOT
JUST ASK QUESTIONS WHERE THERE'S
SO MUCH -- IN THOSE HEARINGS.
SOME OF THE WORDS BEING SAID NOW
PORTRAY THE SUNSHINE SOLDIERS AS
THEY ARE ANYTHING ELSE AND I
DON'T THINK THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE CAPITOL POLICE NEED THE FAIR
WEATHER FRIENDS THAT SO MANY OF
THESE MEMBERS ARE TALKING ABOUT
NOW.
WE NEED A DETAILED, HONEST
INVESTIGATION.
AND IT'S V